Earthquake early warning systems can give people
crucial seconds to move to safety,
but only if they get the message in time.
Now scientists are shaking up
what we know about such systems.
New research suggests that
giving people enough time to act
before a sizeable tremor may also
mean sending out a few false alarms.
All earthquakes start with P-waves,
which are fast moving and cause little damage.
S-waves come next.
They move more slowly, but cause more destruction.
Current early warning systems measure
ground movement during the fast P-waves
to predict how much shaking the S-waves will cause,
and then send out an alert.
P waves are fast, compressive waves
that push and pull the ground
in the same direction as the wave,
causing little noticeable ground movement.
S waves, while slower,
move the ground up, down, and side-to-side,
perpendicular to the direction of the wave,
causing great amounts of damage.
Warnings can be transmitted
much faster than S-waves move, giving people
time to take action before the damaging waves hit
To find out how much warning time
these alerts could give people,
researchers imagined a system
where people could set their own alerts,
based not on the actual magnitude of the quake, but on
how violent the tremors would be at their location,
from “barely noticable” to “very strong.”
Scientists then calculated how big the earthquake
would need to be to cause those levels of
shaking at different distances.
Someone 10 kilometers from the epicenter, for example,
would experience more severe shaking
from a lower magnitude earthquake
than a person 100 kilometers away.
Finally, researchers estimated how long it would take
to send out an alert.
Because a more powerful earthquake
takes a longer time to develop,
alerts took longer to produce if they were
triggered by larger magnitude shakes.
In fact, people at most distances from
the epicenter would receive no warning at all
before a large S-wave hit.
But predictions for low-level shaking
could be sent out quickly, giving people
tens of seconds to act.
The downside?
Many users could see the alerts as false alarms
if the quake never develops
into a more powerful tremor.
But if it does, it could save lives:
Trains could slow down, and planes could
delay takeoffs until the threat passes.
That means that even alerts generated for
small, insignificant quakes could be incorporated
into earthquake preparedness training, so that
people are ready when the big one really does hit.